Attention Deficit Hyperactivity Disorder (ADHD) is one of the most common psychiatric illnesses
Between children and adolescents. But what happens inside minds and bodies
Can it be considered an advantage?
While some external factors such as drinking alcohol and smoking may affect pregnancy
On brain development, hyperactivity is closely related to your genes. And more
These genes are directly related to the pathways of brain satisfaction. It turned out later
That those with attention deficit and hyperactivity have low levels of dopamine receptors (and dopamine is the hormone responsible for
Satisfaction and happiness). This means they are less likely to feel rewarded, so they are more likely to be bored
Or they are not affected by things that usually delight others.
We also observe clear differences when considering MRI scans of the brains of the injured. The brain usually appears to be in a state of stillness
In the normal case area, and quickly changes to the active task area
In case you need attention. But the brains of people with attention deficit and hyperactivity fail
In automatic switching between the two regions, which means both areas remain active
This results in a decrease in their ability to concentrate. Scientists also noted lightness in the frontal cortex of the brain in patients with the disease,
He is responsible for controlling attention, regulating emotions and discouraging response.
As a result of these differences, Ritalin is usually given to patients who are infected;
The concentration of dopamine in neural connections increases the likelihood of its association with the few receptors
However, there are conflicting studies on its effectiveness and concerns
Of long-term side effects. Of course, many people without attention deficit and hyperactivity were known
Abuse of medication as a means of increasing concentration during work or study, to study more efficiently
Perhaps the most controversial is the dramatic rise in the diagnosis of the disease over the years.
Whether justified or not, there is a registered increase of 5% every year from 2003-2011
in the United States. The same pattern was followed in describing treatments with some reports showing
The increase in the disbursement of medicines by 35% between 2008 and 2012.
It later emerged that there may be a developed advantage for patients with attention deficit and hyperactivity.
For fishermen in nomadic or migratory communities, being active and moving, this makes
The chances of success of their hunting and returning home to food are stronger and greater, and increase caution and vigilance
To protect their children. This means greater survival and survival opportunities for passing genes across generations
A current study of Bedouin and urban individuals from the Arial tribe in Kenya is shown
The Bedouin who have a greater frequency of genes associated with attention deficit and hyperactivity are better at getting food
Moreover. Studies routinely show that patients have a greater sense of creativity
Both in controlled tests and in real life, where they usually think randomly and out of the box
Finally, the structure of the study environment is tight and unable to deal with the affected children
With hypotension and hyperactivity, many adults thrive in appropriate work environments. Studies show
That if their explosive energies were directed to the right professions, especially those that needed a high degree of skill
And adaptation, those who are considered to be in need will become strong supporters.
Special thanks for audible to support this episode by giving you a free 30 day period
On audible.com/asap This week we wanted to nominate 'The ADHD Advantage' by Dale Archer
As it highlights the most successful entrepreneurs, leaders, and artists
They derived their strength from their illness. You can get a free 30-day period at audible.com/asap
And choose from our big group! We love it because it's great when you review it.
And participated in the channel for more scientific sections weekly.